bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got sam
here what's up man
hanging out in miami doing d5 d-gen
stuff
uh you know that's literally all i want
to talk to you about is d5 degen stuff
this world is crazy there's
literally a coin right now called come
rocket that is exploding
uh safe moon i lift one more person
messaged me about safe moon i don't
think it's safe i don't think it's going
to the moon but that's what they all
keep saying
uh let's start with your background what
did you do before consensus
so uh a long time ago i was a computer
scientist and cognitive scientist
i did a lot of applied science after
that so basically uh did a lot of work
trying to unify
work on human cognition and computation
then ended up working at
an offshoot of the johns hopkins applied
physics laboratory
called sensorstar where we built like
robotics and computer vision
stuff like that and i was always trying
to be at the cutting edge of science
that's actually what ended up leading me
to cryptocurrency in general because i
thought that actually monetary
technology was one of the cutting edges
of
human cognition so you're doing smart
[ __ ] yeah smart nerd stuff
and then you know realize that building
smart nerd stuff
for other big companies doesn't make
that much money and i learned what
entrepreneurship was
and then sort of started going in that
direction how do you get to consensus
uh so i was into bitcoin from the very
beginning uh from the you know white
paper stage
just from a money nerd perspective wish
i had bought every
sold on my clothes and bought it but did
you buy any a little bit
uh but you know wish i had done more um
but you know
mostly just normally we feel really bad
for you
so thanks um you know so you know
over time uh you know kind of stopped
paying attention to bitcoin honestly
because everyone was making like a
wallet or an exchange
or selling drugs on the internet i
didn't really want to do any of those as
a business
um but i heard about this in ethereum no
one could explain to me what it was
uh and then you know i watched it and
then i heard
uh there's this guy gonna explain what
it is in new york and so
met joe lubin at that event uh
describing what ethereum was
immediately he said it was a
decentralized virtual machine as a
computer scientist i knew what that was
and i was like oh my god that's gonna
change the world
so uh ended up a few weeks later joining
up with joe
building consensus uh i was chief
strategy officer of there for
like you know the first how big is it
when you joined it was me and a few
other people kind of a loose group of
people but it was
me joe maybe like two or three other
people in a room
all right and what's the vision for
consensus when you start uh
it was to collect the smartest people
around
in uh that knew what ethereum was which
was probably only a handful of people on
the planet at the time
that could actually write software um
start building
basically a what we call a hub and spoke
model but essentially
uh started seeding the ecosystem was our
goal right
it was kind of like 1991 and we know
that http
is going to be an amazing protocol but
you know the web browser doesn't exist
and the apache web server doesn't exist
and someone's got to build all that
stuff and we know that you know we can
think of
you know a social network and we can
start building that and we can use that
to motivate the construction of those
lower layers which is what we did we
you know we funded truffle and fear of
metamask all the stuff that we needed to
actually build on ethereum
allowed other people to build on
ethereum so we basically seeded that
whole ecosystem
the entire time you're working there are
you getting paid in ether
uh no in the in the early days uh it was
some crypto uh but then eventually it
became like a normal
corporation we have to like pretend to
like have a real account
okay uh just before everyone gets all
upset
i feel like if we sat down everybody oh
he's the ethereum guy and i'm the
bitcoin guy
[ __ ] all that that's all labels it's all
stupid uh what is your view
of ethereum and what's your view of
bitcoin today like how do you think of
those two assets are they competing with
each other are they two different things
what are they just walk me through that
framework you use
i think they're driven by completely
different narratives right so bitcoin
you know if you talk to someone on wall
street you know the narrative they've
heard probably is
it's digital gold right it's a you know
not to offend any bitcoin people you
know but
it's a slow moving asset and that's sort
of a feature not a bug right it's not
going to change
no developer is going to come change the
mechanics of its issuance
right people get mad about you know
vitalik might change the way that it
gets issued and therefore it's not hard
money or whatever right
um but you can you can rely on that
narrative the bitcoin is going to stay
basically what it is
and it's kind of and it can be sort of a
reserve asset in that sense so
fair to categorize as uh if a trade-off
is security versus like innovation
speed etc it's choosing security over
the others yeah
totally okay um ethereum ethereum i see
as a programmatic substrate for
a new economy right it is what does that
mean it now smart nurture
so you know so it's it's it's it's the
operating system
for how what you could build on top of
it which is other financial applications
right or other trust-based applications
and ethereum is like the fuel to that
right it's sort of
if the internet if http had had a money
built into it or a
token of value it's like that right
except it's explicitly
a type of financial internet and so it's
the base unit of that and it's almost
like it's a commodity that powers that
whole thing
do you think that they compete with each
other or are they two separate things
like
how do you think about uh i think the
narrative publicly is like bitcoin
versus eth market cap first market cap
asset versus asset is that fair or do
you think that's misguided
in some cases they compete with each
other right i mean it competes with each
other for
for mind share right like some people
are uh
institutions are investing in bitcoin
because they know it's going to be
valuable over time they don't quite
understand the ethereum narrative yet i
think they will
and so i do think they compete a little
bit in that sense of like this is going
to be a
permanent and important asset but they
do occupy different
headspaces essentially in different
market niches um
they also compete a little bit or
starting to compete a little bit in
the application layer right like there
have been a lot of people have tried
to launch application layers on top of
bitcoin most of them haven't gone
anywhere
but it's been enough years people are
starting to do it and so you know
ethereum obviously is way far ahead
there are other uh competitors to
ethereum too that also have like added
some incremental feature on top of
ethereum or changed it um
like other smart contract platforms yeah
exactly so you know so those are
it's starting to compete a little bit in
those domains but in general they
they're the venn diagram is not
that crossing over yeah so
let's go right at i think one of the big
things that uh the ethereum community
continues to say that
the bitcoin community is like you guys
are idiots like there's no way that's
true it's this idea of ethan's money
i think the ethereum community is like
hey you guys are idiots in the bitcoin
community for whatever reason around
bitcoin is money
right uh do you think it is money and
then how do you
kind of process just as currency those
two assets
i honestly don't have that strong like
one of those religious opinions of
ethan's money
a lot of people tweet that and it's a
point of contention great tweet
it gets a lot of engagement right yeah i
mean you know
if you ask an economist what money is
right it's something like
fungible you know store value tangible
or like
not necessarily tangible but you know
portable like it has these properties
right i think ethereum
mostly meets those properties i don't
know the us dollar qualifies as a store
value but
um you know it it checks a lot of those
boxes you can use it to pay for stuff
right now
people do pay for stuff with it um but i
honestly don't think that's the most
important debate
right and ethereum one of the big
criticisms of ethereum
from the bitcoin community is that it uh
it has no capped supply
um and the only way you can kind of
estimate how much supply it'll have is
by looking at its issuance over time
with the new with eip1559 like the new
rollouts of ethereum and ethereum 2.0
it actually looks like it might be
slightly deflationary or steady state
um so you know but it's a different
flavor you know there's
you know x number of bitcoins right so
there's set
issuance obviously with bitcoin it's
programmatic transparent all stuff
with ethereum i think that is the big
knock from bitcoiners right is hey
whoever can change it uh
expand or contract the supply uh i think
the ethereum communities arguments like
their security related
issues as to why you would do that uh
and so like
it's fair just like say okay that's the
line in the sand and like whichever side
you agree you agree
fair sure yeah like
if you think one's more valuable than
the other then like that's what you're
gonna
kind of oscillate around right yeah i
mean you know
they both solve the same problem uh you
know
i think a lot of the distinction is
religious more than intellectual
right now that we got that out of the
way i want you to tell me what the hell
is going on in the most degenerate defy
corners
of the world uh and i say that so for
those that don't know
there is this entire world of uh some of
this is
outright scams some of this is outright
like moonshot ideas of like let's go
take down the financial system
some of it is like we just built cool
technology we don't have a use case for
it right there's all kinds of stuff
happening here
yeah but uh when you think of like d gen
d phi slash ethereum world like what is
happening there what does that
constitute yeah so i'll start by saying
uh
d-gen is actually like a complement yeah
yeah yeah okay we should start that's a
great
so you know it is degenerate and and it
you know it refers to the fact that
people are
you know throwing lots of money around
in different smart contracts and doing
things
like really are fairly financially
degenerate in the normal world
but there's also a tremendous amount of
value that's being created because
people are creating new financial
primitives and they're bootstrapping the
liquidity of those primitives
i can explain what that means but you
know essentially what's happened
is over last summer there's this this
era that
people call defy summer happened and a
lot of it was instigated by this
uh the protocol called yern finance and
what they did
is they they really changed the game of
how you
can launch a protocol within d5 right
so one of the problems anyone has when
they're launching a company
that has infrastructure involved in it
is you need to get people to use the
infrastructure
dfi has the same problem where if i make
a protocol for lending or i make a
protocol for
you know tracking some synthetic asset
and no one's using it there's no
liquidity in the
in the program uh it doesn't work right
so founders need a way to get
liquidity in there if you think about
the capital markets you know
people need some of the same stuff in
normal companies too right that's why we
have underwriters
is because they they introduce liquidity
they help they help write the price uh
you know correct the price
um of something when it launches and so
you know you need those things you need
to set the price you need to interest
liquidity
you need to get the thing launching to
issue the the new asset or whatever
and so what yearn did is they figured
out a new mechanism that no one had
thought of before
that people call liquidity mining um and
so
well maybe some people have thought of
that idea but they hadn't used it in
this way to completely bootstrap
something
and this is really just going after the
cold start problem right is we want to
do this but we need the liquidity
or it won't work and so how do we
incentivize people to come in give us
liquidity
and give them some sort of economic
incentive for doing that
and then we can get to kind of scale and
have the liquidity that we need
yeah yeah exactly so that actually
doesn't sound so crazy
when you say it that way yeah d-gen d-pi
sounds ridiculous to most people right
but go ahead
yeah i mean the the part where it gets
really dj is that
uh when when people started designing
these mechanisms that essentially reward
you for providing liquidity sometimes
they don't know exactly how to set
the issuance rate like they set it in
the smart contract
and you you know say i put i put a
million bucks inside the smart contract
which they want me to do
that might give me 10 000 or it might
give me 10 million dollars back as a
reward and it depends on how they set
the parameters and what other people are
doing and so sometimes
you can get these really ridiculous
returns right you're putting something
in a smart contract where it's
1500 apy return right
which is absurd from a normal finance
perspective and that's why it's
degenerate but some of those things are
scams and you lose all your money
and you know distinguishing those things
is hard how do you know how do you
specifically know
when it's a scam versus like oh this is
just great d5 returns
so you know there's a larger story there
which is you know i have
an organization that works on this uh
called alignment engine
and what we do is we're we just helped
launch and and service this thing called
the neptune dao
the neptune dao is a liquidity providing
dao
uh and we have engineers that are
excellent at auditing smart contracts
that actually
probably audited those specific
contracts before uh and we can look at
them and make sure it's not a scam but
okay so hold on back up back up back up
a liquidity dow what is that
so essentially uh people have realized
especially people on the forefront of
the dj
game uh have realized that they want
exposure to this this new game right and
it's a new
it's a new type of market participation
that actually has real value and helps
protocols bootstrap
much like venture helps early protocols
you know helps early founders rather
than raise a seed round you go and you
get liquidity
you do a liquidity deal and in fact you
know there's a new
whole type of deal that's emerging where
founders will approach us
you know private leave and say hey look
we need to guarantee this much will you
like help us out or we need to move our
smart contracts from l1 to l2 and we
don't have enough
money to do it um can you help us out so
like we're kind of a new type of market
participant
um but essentially it's a bunch it's a
pooled vehicle it's
malloc contracts if anyone's familiar
with those other dials like the lao or
the flamingo dow the same one
but it's a pool of money so i'm gonna
laugh the whole time at the names
because only in crypto but
yeah we get we get weird but you know
it's a it's a pool of money it's full of
liquidity that we can do
whatever the governance mechanism says
we can do with it but mostly what we
want to do with it
is help protocols bootstrap their
liquidity and get rewarded for it so
we're almost like we're an early stage
capital markets liquidity provider but
we're doing it in this weird on-chain
way that we do
with engineers uh instead of you know
guys in a stock market or something
okay what's the craziest thing you've
seen happen
like the absolute most insane thing that
even people who are into crypto will be
like
that's nuts uh that's an interesting one
a lot of weird stuff happens
um you know there was a
there was a protocol that launched over
last summer called based
um and it was very explicitly a game
theoretic game
um you know i think their words were
designed to transfer
money from the the weak hands to the
strong um but it but essentially
you know the they had designed the
mechanics such that it would go in these
extreme oscillations like up
a thousand percent or two thousand
percent and then down to nothing and
then the liquidity would get pulled out
and then you couldn't sell it
and then it would drive it back up etc
so like people had
figured out this extremely new unheard
of game
that caused wild price fluctuations and
actually
does end up benefiting the owners over
time if you hold on to this token
because they've done other air drops or
whatever but
um basically the emergence of a new type
of financial game it's a little bit like
gambling and a little bit like investing
and a little bit like engineering
all in one is it fair to say this is all
entertainment like literally when they
create that thing
based right i've never heard of that
before uh but
the fact that it goes up so much that it
goes down so much is like almost
a uh a toy right it's like one you can
sit and watch and i'm sure people love
watching like oh we're up 2000 went down
whatever
uh there's an economic element of like
i'm sure people try to sell it at the
top and buy it at the bottom and
sometimes you're right sometimes you're
wrong uh but then there's this other
element of like it's so freaking crazy
that you probably get entertainment and
like talking to your friends about it
yeah i mean definitely i mean that that
was very much like very meme heavy
like you know a little bit like gambling
but it also it
that project specifically i think has
some real merit to it but
but a lot of these things like
tendencies why does someone have
because they keep well it was a game and
it is a game i think but they are
launching some real stuff
and they're sort of secretly doing it
it's an anonymous project and
they sort of slowly roll out these
things but then you're like whoa
actually that is a real
utility platform uh no no
all right so like real anonymity yeah
it's it's yeah
it's anonymous um and and you're seeing
that a lot now right because partially
because the regulatory clarity is not
there to be able to launch stuff
but sometimes it's like fake anonymity
like sometimes it's like
oh sam launched a new project he's using
you know i don't know
based whatever is his you know pseudonym
but like everyone knows it's sam yeah
and other times it's like literally
nobody knows
yeah no this is like nobody knows and
it's you know partially because
it's uh you don't you don't know what's
going on right and also
you know uh liability comes from
identity right so it's i i think we're
seeing an
era of a lot of anonymous founders right
and to the extent that there's not
regulatory clarity and to the extent
that
uh you know people want to do things
that might be beyond regulatory
understanding at all
they're going to be more and more
anonymous people so um
but so you know another ridiculous one
attendees that's definitely a game right
it's basically a pyramid scheme
and it and if you run out of the top
holders then money flows up to you and
it was yeah in in our wall street bets
uh famous for pumping
like gamestop you know we like to say
identified a market structure issue and
short squeeze hedge funds
i'm sorry i i'm corrected um so uh
you know attendees is what they call
money in their parlance and so attendees
is like a play on that that's very
explicitly a game uh some of these
things though are real right and a lot
of what we're doing
within neptune dao is we're actually
we're trying to take a long-term
position
in these assets and these things
sometimes uh
like venture capital has gotten a bad
rap uh within crypto
deservedly so in many cases because you
know uh the distribution is concentrated
uh the thing launches it gets dumped on
retail
uh the project suffers for that and it's
retail investors suffer for that
and uh and people think that's not a
healthy distribution so actually a lot
of projects launching will say
we don't have a venture around there are
no vcs involved that's actually
that's a feature not a bug right and so
when these things launch they launch
with often
no liquidity and they call it a fair
launch there was also this movement last
summer
to fair launch projects meaning that
anyone can come participate in the very
beginning
by providing liquidity and if you help
bootstrap the thing then
you're one of the early participants one
of the holders and the teams don't take
tokens in those fair launches
or they still take tokens sometimes
often no i mean i'm sure the
teams have probably figured out some way
to help farm it for themselves you know
and that's one of the things
you know we might want to do right it's
like what do founders need you know
like maybe we want to help them farm it
or whatever but
i don't think those mechanics have been
completely determined and what's fair i
think the market probably isn't
necessarily demanding that people have
no founder tokens but
you know more towards that edge not like
a venture round where the founder has
like 75
or something it's like the founders get
like 10 right but
um but essentially what's interesting
for us is in the beginning of these
protocols
if you wanted to buy a venture style
like amount an amount significant to a
fund
you can't do it because the tokens come
into existence
through this process of providing
liquidity so the only way you can get
these tokens
is by helping them bootstrap and so and
when you say help them bootstrap or
provide liquidity
are you talking about taking eth in most
cases and basically providing it
in some smart contract you know uh
or some kind of liquidity pool and then
leaving it there
and you're almost earning yield on your
assets and then that's
you're giving them the liquidity you're
earning that yield but that yields paid
in the token of the
yeah yeah essentially so it's a little
bit like you know amazon credits given
to startups or something they want to
incentivize
uh people to come provide liquidity so
it's an example like let's say
uh let's say i'm building a new swap
like a competitor to uniswap
right which is an automated market maker
swapping facility
um so you go to it you put one asset
another as it comes out but you need you
need people who have staked or like put
in both sides of that asset pair for it
to work
sushi swap came along last summer wanted
to have that same functionality but
there's
you know there's billions of dollars in
unit swap how do you get billions of
dollars in the new protocol so that
people can actually use it
what they did is they said if you take
your uh unit swap
liquidity and you move it over to sushi
swap we'll start spitting out sushi swap
tokens into your wallet
right and by doing that you know and if
you calculate the yields on that
it's really high it's like hundreds of
percent or something right so people
said of course yeah i'm going to migrate
that liquidity over
and hence sushi swap was born and that's
how they got their liquidity so
uh i was telling you beforehand um the
way that i view this has
changed from a framework standpoint at
first it was
uh everyone's saying yield but they're
not actually generating yield what
they're saying is
sam you know take your liquidity out of
one place put it with me and then i'm
going to give you yield
and what that insinuates right for the
legacy world is that they're going to
take your assets they're going to go
they're going to lend it out right
rehypothecate it
they're going to generate a rate of
return they're going to take a
percentage of that rate of return
they're going to basically then give you
a piece of it right so i generate 10 i
give you eight i hold on to two
and that's how the system would work
here what they were basically doing is
they just created a bunch of tokens
right put it into uh treasury
essentially and they said sam you should
come here and give us your liquidity and
when you do that we're just gonna take
tokens out of our own thing we're just
gonna dump them on you right and we're
gonna give you hundreds of percent and
over time it gets commoditized down
uh one the rates were unsustainable i
think everyone kind of understood that
two was it wasn't really true yield from
like a lending or rehypothecation
standpoint it was just
uh the use of the tokens or these
airdrops or whatever
what somebody said to me that i think is
actually a fair point is
uh wait a second that's just customer
acquisition cost
now the difference is uh rather than
take money let's say if i had a normal
company that i raised money from a
venture capitalist and then i use it and
i pay facebook and google for
advertising to acquire users or i say
similar how paypal said you know ten
dollars for every person you
invite you get ten dollars here you're
not using
dollars or capital that you raised
you're actually using some
currency or asset or whatever that you
created right and so that would be like
amazon saying hey here's a hundred
thousand dollars of amazon credits
it's not actually dollars just something
they created all right so all that
is out there agree or disagree that
that's the right way to look i
i agree and i think it's also it also
has the byproduct of
distributing your asset and creating
your assets so it's not necessarily
that they have it in the treasury
already and they dump it on you it's
that that
is the event that generates the token to
begin with which is something they
needed to do
they need to have some distribution
schedule or logic of how that gets
created
so it does that for them and then it
puts the you know the
the base asset of the protocol in the
hands of lots of different people which
people believe is a healthy distribution
economically for that thing so
it so it's like customer acquisition and
it's also like
some other capital markets kind of
functions if we take a hundred percent
of this world
and i said to you what percentage is
scams what percentage is games and what
percentage is real
are we 90 real in your opinion
five percent five percent of scams and
games
what's like the breakdown or 90 scams
and
five percent really like how would you
from your opinion break down
uh between those three planets i think
there's like a sliding scale
that depends on that scares me that's
your answer
well you know it well it's it's a time a
time slider let's say so like
when ethereum started doing this a lot
of the projects that we're launching
were legitimate and they were
experimental because no one ever thought
of this before
but they were legitimately trying to do
something and then you know
a month goes by two months goes by
everybody and their brother has
the source code of that and can launch a
new scam one and then that turns into 90
scams right okay same thing just
happened on bsc which is
uh binance guidance basically took
ethereum
ripped out all the decentralization and
put it is finance going to disrupt
ethereum
i don't think so no why not uh
well you know there's a there's a small
group of people that can turn off
binance smart chain
uh and so you know are there a small
group of people that could
roll back ethereum uh not
physically no i mean you have to get
every or you know 51
of all the miners in the world uh or
more than that even i think you could
argue um
but uh i don't know enough about bsc
ethereum differences to know
what to ask there so so bs i mean
ethereum has like you know thousands of
node operators all over the world that
don't know each other right like tens of
thousands at least
of miners that are all mining it and
they all have to agree
if they wanted to change something right
which generally isn't going to happen
unless it's something really important
like upgrading to ethereum 2.0 or
something right
um with bsc what they did is they ripped
out all that stuff that makes it so that
there are thousands of
uh unaffiliated nodes all over the world
and they just made it some like servers
that binance but it still is compatible
with like metamask and like other
ethereum like ethereum code can run on
it stuff like that
so so what you had was bsc launched it's
much cheaper to run stuff on bsc because
the gas prices of ethereum got really
high
uh so you could launch these farms
initially there are probably some people
you know building real things like
pancake swap is a real thing
um i've actually heard of that one yeah
uh yeah it has a big market cap like it
has real utility
um if you believe bsc has really
utilitate but uh and then
you know and or people were saying well
it's too expensive to launch on ethereum
i'm gonna launch on bsc and maybe i'll
move to ethereum later or something else
later right
so it has that real utility um and uh
but then you know that's so cheap and so
easy over time
you know 90 of that was eventually scams
i think it probably is
right now okay uh when you think about
this entire world
i'm gonna ask you for the bullish view
and then the critique
we'll start with uh the critique first
and then we'll we'll move to the bullet
view
uh the ethereum slash smart contracts
like uh
all the platforms that are not bitcoin
what's the biggest critique or like the
biggest risk so if you said hey you know
uh in order to be bullish on something i
also have to be the one who can like
articulate the the other side of the
argument the best
what do you think is like the fair
critiques of ethereum or like this whole
world and maybe you say there are none
it's perfect vitalik
is uh god um well so that's gonna be a
meme somebody mean that
um so you know i think some of the
criticisms
are probably rightfully around the edge
cases of
of trust and the things that we build
into the real world
for human error and jurisprudence
and gray areas right like a lot of
people are on this
sort of kick of code is law and you know
this can actually completely replace
everything about the trust
infrastructure of humans and the fact of
the matter is
there's a soft side to why humans trust
each other and how they trust each other
and
there's a clause in every contract that
says well if this contract doesn't
actually specify what to do
when we just we dispute it then this is
how you dispute it and you go to
arbitration and you go to this court
and you talk to humans about it right so
i think
while we can over time dramatically
make more efficient and faster and
cheaper
a large part of the trust infrastructure
of the world like court systems and
law enforcement and lawyers and stuff
like that we can't totally eliminate it
so i think
you know i think uh that immutability
and that sort of uh that hard-lineness
about the way it
it behaves is both a feature and a bug
um and it makes it probably not rise up
to
completely replacing everything about
how we deal with finance and trust
but it can take us farther than we are
right now for sure
okay what's the bullish case
like is eth the global reserve currency
in the future in your opinion
is this the protocol on which every
financial application in the world
runs on yeah so um
you know to yes i
possibly and you know not to both yeah
to both i mean
either ether or something like it and
you know not to talk
my book right like i have an open mind
uh i personally really like ethereum and
i think it has the strongest case
for taking that on um now that we've
realized that there can be this
decentralized trust infrastructure that
is dramatically cheaper right and people
talk about
you know the environmental impact of
crypto or whatever but
the right comparison is not crypto or
nothing the right comparison is
ethereum crypto versus like every bank
building in the world every court system
in the world all the
miles driven to those court cases and by
lawyers and police forces and
all the money you spend on military to
like enforce the rule of law and
do you know the energy consumption of
the meteor uh industry
i don't but it is way too high it should
be a national crisis
like somebody should write about that
right like
they literally print physical papers how
many trees get killed
just so we're very clear um being
facetious to a degree but like that is
the
outrageousness of the argument right is
if we basically said look at how many
trees the media industry is killing we
should shut down the media industry
yeah like people would be like that's
absurd yeah okay
that's exactly what you're saying about
crypto yeah and it's like if you don't
understand that
cutting down those trees has some value
then yeah maybe it seems
makes sense but it doesn't because it's
really useful so people people haven't
yet
grocked that this could be a replacement
for large parts of that stuff that we
spend lots of resources on right
it can replace as i'm saying like the
trust infrastructure
all that all those police and courts and
lawyers and whatever that we need in
order
to do business with each other and trust
each other
if that were uh if we could replace all
that with something cheaper and better
faster that looked like the internet
and that internet had a money built into
it or
a you know something of value built into
it people get
upset about the word money but if it had
a native asset built into it
if http if your web browser since the
early 90s had
had a money built into it that would
probably be pretty freaking valuable
um i think that's the bull case for it
what are the odds that
what i'm about to say is true bitcoin
first digital currency rate uh people
want to do more with it
they can't smart contracts composability
etc they go in the build ethereum and
then
a plethora of other smart contract
platforms the belief is that you can
scale in layer one
they don't move to layer two scalability
at the same time bitcoin is
layer two as well uh now that there's
smart contracts on bitcoin
smart contracts on ethereum uh they both
coexist
some people will choose to have vertical
integration between what they deem is
the hard sound money
with these digital decentralized kind of
smart contract based
d5 applications uh on bitcoin and then
in the ethereum world people see ethan's
money and they go and they
vertically integrate digital
decentralized smart contract you know d5
applications
on that ethos money thesis does that
seem
like where we're headed maybe
um i sound like you don't agree
well you know you're allowed to disagree
as much as you want so you you know
honestly more about the bitcoin
ecosystem than i do like i you know i
obviously i don't
because you know more about ethereum
than i do so
you know so i spent many years like
pretty much only thinking about ethereum
and but that was the only thing that was
doing anything like that for many years
in fairness so and anything else trying
to do that was
basically trying to copy ethereum right
so um
is it the case that people are building
smart contracts on top of bitcoin
yes like what makes a smart contract
platform successful
a lot of things one of the things is
community right
another thing is liquidity you can't
really fork community or liquidity
and it's very difficult especially
between the bitcoin and theorem
communities to get that crosstalk so i
ask you the million dollar question
which community
is uh is uh more vibrant bitcoin or
ethereum
well you know uh if you like like
unicorns and uh you know anime
and also the future of finance ethereum
if you like like stick and like ludwig
von mises
probably bitcoin oh yeah
we're both we're both in trouble
[Laughter]
that's actually a very good answer to a
nearly impossible question
[Laughter]
by the way bitcoiners do like steak and
uh mises so like yeah
that you correctly identify they do not
probably actually like unicorns uh or
anime so like
okay when uh when you think about
the institutions are coming right that
was a whole thing i think
bitcoin was kind of the first asset
that's the one everyone's really focused
on institutions now started by bitcoin
uh is your expectation that they'll
eventually buy ether they'll go into
you know ethereum based d5 they'll go
participate in all these lending and
liquidity stuff uh and they'll like
wall street will become degen over time
or like like what
or is that all fantasy land and like
they're just gonna buy bitcoin maybe
they'll buy some ethan like that's it
yeah i mean i think i think there's a
few layers of that right they're
obviously already buying bitcoin um
if you looked at the last few days of
ethereum uh
you know it looks like somebody big is
buying a bunch of ethereum i'm not sure
but i don't think it's very long and i
think it's probably already the case
that
people have said okay what's the second
biggest one
bitcoin just went up we should have done
what elon did we should have done what
paul turner jones did
um maybe this smaller one has some room
to run
that's already happening right um so
that's easy that'll definitely happen
and it's already happening a little bit
um the second phase of that though is d5
degen stuff
right a lot of this stuff has
the regulatory clarity of you know mud
and the you know when they have their
limited partnership agreements
and they have their regulatory you know
compliance
guys and you know they look at that it
freaks them out right and
some of the stuff that's completely
decentralized there's almost no way
that you could you could touch that from
the current perspective right
that said i often talk to large well
capitalized hedge fund guys are like
i really wish i could work on this can i
work for you actually yeah
so um i think i think the you know the
people are
the especially the the younger
generations are pulling people in that
direction
um and there's gonna be there's already
so much yield there's so much money
being made
there's you know just like bitcoin was
five years ago
just like ethereum was three years ago
or whatever
um it takes a while for them to catch up
but they're gonna realize
that there's so much money to be made
and there's also you know the future of
finance to be constructed and to be a
part of and you know
wells fargo their logo is a horse-drawn
carriage
right um they figured out they need to
do something different i'm
i'm sure they'll figure out you know the
next thing too uh it'll take time though
that's actually a great point i always
forget that
you've thought about this before all
right i know we gotta go
uh i got three questions to finish up
you'll get to ask me one uh
first is what's the most important book
you've ever read
the most important book i've ever read
uh
i think you might have asked me this
before so i'll probably i don't know if
i'll say the same book but
uh probably a book called synergetics by
buckminster fuller
um why i don't think that's what you
said last time um yeah
uh so in terms of like it being an
important book
it's basically his like magnum opus of
everything that he studied
in science and looking at the structure
of nature
and how nature informs design and if you
want to essentially if
if evolution constructs reality uh
the phrase every any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from nature i think
is true because over time evolution will
wear down anything
that doesn't meet certain uh
efficiencies certain design patterns
that nature has discovered
over billions of years and this is his
explication in deep scientific detail
of why you see the same patterns in
plants and stars and galaxies and
subatomic particles and
metal alloys and whatever and it's just
a beautiful
scientific representation of that and i
think is contains a lot of the design
patterns
of where our species will go if it
survives
that was actually a great answer great
job
next one's from eight sleep they've got
thermoregulated bed
basically i make it cold as [ __ ] and go
to sleep and sleep forever you should
not do that
uh what's your sleep pattern like do you
sleep a lot not a lot
you know uh allow you to sleep it's a
funny question yeah d-gen world is a
24-7 world and like last summer i was
probably i i would like you know uh
pass off the baton to my wife and when
she was getting up i'd probably go to
sleep
um so i sleep in
short amounts uh i like it to be cold
and
uh but not nearly enough and i don't
think i will over the next uh
you know year as we build out the djinn
ecosystem so
usually i would ask about aliens we've
already talked about it uh previously
so my question to you is is it fair to
call you the king of the degens
is that is that an applicable title here
i mean
you know i don't know i don't know i
wasn't a no i i don't want to name
myself that that's a you know all right
but if you name it i would accept it
okay so the king of the dj's you know
i mean d gens i think what i do is i
bridge the d gens right
because because i'm i'm in the chat
rooms with with teenagers
that are working on d5 protocols in the
middle of the night and i'm also
you know by some people's estimation a
normal
business person financial professional
and so i try to bridge those worlds
all right that's fair but i'm sort of
like king of the djs
you're gonna ask me one question what
you got for me um
what is uh
what is the best answer you've received
about whether aliens exist
um probabilistically yes but they're
also probabilistically too far away
therefore their existence won't be
recognized by us because we'll never be
able to communicate with them they'll
never be able to communicate with us
for you know hundreds of thousands of
years and i think that's
probably the best answer because that's
the answer i believe
of like just like yeah like the the
galaxies are too big
something's probably out there but we
can't even get to mars let alone
anywhere else so like we're never gonna
know about it
yup fair enough or they're already all
around us
you could be an alien you could be the
alien of the djs
all right where can we find people to
find you on the internet uh where do you
want to send the people
uh probably my twitter is that's just at
sam cassette
um and uh check out the the
neptune.neptunedow.xyz
the neptune being the gothic i can't
believe i'm allowing this right now
all right man thank you so much for
doing this we'll do it again thank you
very much very cool